[Musique]
j'ai 10 ans et je suis née ici à
Miami j'adore être pom pom girl
j'encourage mon école je la représente
et parfois je fais des
compétitions mon frère est un joueur de
basketball il adore jouer au basket et
moi je suis pom pom girl donc je
l'encourage lui
aussi mais avec la situation actuelle de
mes parents et leur statut le tps statut
de protection temporaire ils peuvent
être expulsé ce qui voudrait dire que ce
rêve
[Musique]
s j'ai 17 ans j'adore jouer au
basketball je fais aussi de l'athlétisme
et je vais à l'église tous les
weekends je sors avec mes amis après le
lycée en fait je suis un ado
[Musique]
américain quand je pense à l'avenir je
m'imagine toujours vivre
ici je me suis jamais dit que j'irais
vivre en Haïti
et je ne peux imaginer être expulsé vers
le pays natal de mes
parents je suis ici depuis plus de 18
ans je vis aux États-Unis puisque j'ai
laissé Haïti en 99 ça va faire 19 ans je
suis infirmier je travaille pour
l'hôpital de Jackson à Miami un grand
hôpital à
Miami j'ai réalisé pas mal de choses
j'ai des enfants j'ai une maison je
travaille et je pense que je vis le rêve
américain je ferai tout ce qui est dans
mon pouvoir pour rester
[Musique]
ici ce sont des récits de vise
américaines bien
installé 10 ans 19 ans 28 ans aux
États-Unis ils en oublieraiit presque
leur première vie dans leur pays natal
le plus pauvre des Amériques
[Musique]
Haïti un quotidien brutalement
bouleversé par une annonce choc de
l'administration Trump le 6 novembre
2017 le département d'État a indiqué que
les États-Unis allaient mettre fin au
statut de protection temporaire le tps
pour plus plus de 300000 personnes dans
ce pays dont 50000 haïtiens pour la
plupart ici en
Floride les autorités leur ont donné 18
mois pour quitter le territoire où ils
seront
expulsés depuis cette annonce des
dizaines de milliers d'haïtienst fu au
Canada à travers un petit chemin
frontalier
ro pass Mme en plein hiver au péril de
le
vie jus Laor d'accueil des réfugiés
venus
d'Haïti depuis le séisme qui a ravagé
leur pays des dizaines de milliers de
personnes y avaient trouvé refuge grâce
au statut de protection temporaire
accordé à l'époque par Barack Obama un
statut qui régularisait aussi tous ceux
qui avaient fui des années auparavant
les dictatures et la misère à Miami la
communauté haïtienne est réputée
travailleuse bien intégrée et très engag
[Musique]
politiquement en pleine campagne
présidentielle américaine Hillary
Clinton et Donald Trump sét tous les
deux rendus dans leur quartier little
ha le discours de l'homme d'affaires
alors candidat était plein
d'empathie je suis le candidat des
Américains qu'il soit haïtien
afro-américain ou encore asiatique
à tous ceux qui résident ici nous allons
prendre soin de vous que vous votiez
pour moi ou non je veux vraiment être
votre meilleur champion et je serai
votre champion que vous votiez pour moi
ou
[Applaudissements]
non au nord de la Floride les parcs
d'attraction d'Orlando sont réputés dans
le monde entier
Universal Disney World toute une
économie touristique qui repose sur la
main d'œuvre haïtienne
elle travaille dans l'ombre en cuisine à
la maintenance ou au
nettoyage dans cette église évangélique
tout près des grands parcs 90 % des
fidèles sont
haïtien
[Musique]
la suspension du statut de protection
temporaire est l'une des plus grandes
préoccupations du pasteur Charles
[Musique]
Jones une vingtaine de ces fidèles sont
partis depuis un
an
pour nous la séparation n'a pas été
facile du tout il y en a des des maris
et des enfants qui sont laissés derrière
pendant que leur mère ou leur pèr ou
leurs parentés sont partis pour se faire
immigrer au Canada toutes les églises
haïtiennes pas seulement notre église il
y a d'autres églises il y en a des
églises qui en a plus que 50 ou 60
membres quelle que soit l'église
haïtienne quelle que soit là où l'Église
localisée et
ils se sont touchés
également madame Ida fait partie bien
malgré elle de ses familles
séparées sa fille Esther et ses deux
petits enfants viennent de fuir les
États-Unis pour le
Canada ça c'est star ça c'est star ça
c'est ça c'est
Robert
elle rigole tout le
temps ça c'est la dernière photo que
j'ai
elle m'a téléphoné au travail et m'a dit
maman je vais partir au
Canada je lui ai répondu tu pars au
Canada pourquoi
elle a dit qu'elle avait reçu une lettre
qu'elle devait
partir et je lui ai dit Esther n'y va
pas on ne connaît personne là-bas on n'y
est jamais allé on sait pas comment
c'est
c'est très douloureux pour moi mais que
voulez-vous que je fasse je ne peux rien
faire cela faisait 28 ans qu'ester
vivait aux États-Unis au côté de sa mère
qui elle avait réussi à obtenir le droit
de résidence il y a plusieurs
années
bonjour le Canada
oui ah tu
l'aimes tu aimes le Canada et
Orlando et ta grand-mère te
manque je te vois comment ça se passe
tout va
bien regardez comme ils ont grandi je
les ai jamais vu aussi grand regarde
star la fille de Madame Ida 18000
Haïtiens ont quitté les États-Unis pour
le Canada depuis que Donald Trump est
arrivé au pouvoir en janvier
2017 ce nouvel exode est parti d'un
tweet du Premier ministre canadien
Justin trudau une semaine après
l'investiture du président américain à
ce qui fut la persécution la terreur et
la guerre sachez que le Canada vous
accueillera une simple déclaration qui a
considérable dans la communauté
haïtienne
[Musique]
menacée la route est toujours la
même un bus amène d'abord les réfugiés
jusqu'au nord des
[Musique]
États-Unis jusqu'à une station service
de platsburg dans l'État de New
[Musique]
York
vous pouvez m'expliquer où vous allez
bien end on ne sait pas vraiment on sait
qu'on do
traverser quand on sera là-bas
Veron on va devoirporter les personnes
sont sans
papier qu'on va dégager mais le racisme
c'est cause de Donald Trump
y Donal Nim pas les Haïtiens alors comme
ça on ESS de
dégag arrivé à cette station service il
reste encore 40 km à parcourir jusqu'à
rockam Road à la frontière canadienne le
reste du périple s'effectue en
taxi
si vous voulez y aller vous deux et vous
deux ça fait 50 dollars chacun donc 100
dollars pour 4
personnes pour de
familles vous avez beaucoup de C
comm oui tout le
temps les jours tous les jours les gens
ve juste quitter le pays
les
toujours au même
endroit on reste professionnel je suis
taxi c'est un service donc si quelqu'un
doit aller d'un point A à un point B je
les conduis où il doivent aller
[Musique]
entre les États-Unis et le Canada la
plus longue frontière terrestre au monde
kilomè 30 postes frontaliers surveillent
les entrées avec le Québec mais on
compte aussi des milliers de points de
passage
nonoficiel le plus connu se trouve à 30
minutes de route de la station service
de platsburg rocksam Road c'est par là
que la plupart des réfugiés
arrivent en ce mois de janvier les
températures polaires ralentissent le
flot des exil et car cette traversée par
Mo- 20° est dangereuse le froid glacial
a même causé ici qu cas
d'amputation vous voulez des gants un
bonnet tenez prenez une écharpe
aussi Janet vit tout près elle vient
tous les jours distribuer des vêtements
chauds celui c'est pour une petite
fille ce sont des donations des
habitants du quartier pour les réfugiés
on leur donne avant qu'ils traversent la
frontière car la plupart d'entre eux ne
sont pas équipés pour l'hiver donc j'ai
des bonnets des gants des écharpes et
des vestes ce n'est pas ce qu'il y a de
plus joyeux mais au moins ils partent
avec quelque
chose d'une citoyenne américaine d'une
citoyenne américaine qui s'inquiète de
leur
futur arrivé devant le chemin de rocksam
Road c'est ensuite une scène surréaliste
qui se joue
la Gendarmerie Royale met d'abord en
garde ce qui tent d'entrer
illégalement tout votre famille va être
arrêté si vous traversez
ici une simple formalité ces migrants
veulent être arrê sur le sol canadien
pour déposer un dossier de demande
d'asile après quelques pas dans la neige
nous allons devoir vous arrêter ok ils
sont arrêtés dans le calme nous vous
arrêtons pour avoir traversé la
frontière
illégalement s'ils étaient passés par un
poste de douane ils auraient été
renvoyés aux
États-Unis leur avenir au Canada se joue
par cette arrivé illégale sur le
territoire de l'autre côté de la
frontière les douaniers se disent
déborder le président du syndicat des
douanes demande davantage de moyens pour
accueillir les exilés c'est 24 heur sur
24 hein les les les demandeurs d'asile
passent auant de nuit de jour de matin
partant chaud partant froid comme ce
matin ce matin il fait quoi 16 17 de
Celsus c'est quand même très très froid
et souvent ces gensl comme ils arrivent
de Miami ils arrivent la Floride du côté
américain donc faut s'assurer que ces
gens n pas froid sont accueill comme il
se
doit un poste de douane spontané a dû
être
improvisé
on a fait tenir des roulotes de
construction où quand que les gens
arrivent il y en a beaucoup qui portent
même pas de manteau donc ils sont
accueillis ici les policiers
questionnent de façon sommaire après ça
il y a habituellement un petit autobus
qui va arriver et qui va faire le
transport d'ici à environ une dizaine de
minutes de route au bureau de douinee de
Saint-Bernard de la
colle l'été dernier jusqu'à 650
demandeurs d'asile sont arrivés chaque
jour des États-Unis par ce petit
chemin les autorités canadiennes
s'attendent à un nouvel exode massif
dans les mois qui
[Musique]
viennent comme tous ceux qui fuiti au
Canada Esther la fille de Madame Ida
doit réapprendre un nouveau quotidien
avec ses
enfants il fait froid donc il faut que
tu mettes des vêtements chauds je ne
veux pas que tu sois malade ferme bien
ça et ce
bonnet
de parfis il pleure il récl sa grandmère
que ça va pas il dit qu'il veut
rentrer
bien pas du
[Musique]
tout
[Rires]
est arriv illégalement
yquer lesutorit can per de
Tra de
par sy
Gén couverture de la Croix Rouge qui du
jour oanchi la
frontière une pour moi une pour mon fils
une pour ma fille c'est mon histoire ma
vie et c'est le début pas la FA c'est
pour cela que je les garde
[Musique]
elle n'oubliera jamais leur périple de 3
jours en bus 2300 km
d'Orlando à la frontière
canadienne pendant lesquel elle laisse
subitement toute sa vie derrière
elle
j'avais peur mais j'étais forte je ne
voulais pas le montrer aux enfant j'ai
fait comme si c'était un jeu comme si on
partait en voyage je leur ai dit vous
avez vu la neige à la télé on va la voir
en vrai on part en vacances comme si on
allait chez Disney mais c'est très très
loin Esther a passé plus de 30 ans en
Floride après avoir fui
haïtiors que sa famille était assassiné
sous ses
yeux ces dernières années cette maman
célibataire travailler au parc
d'attraction sewor à
Orlando le plus difficile dans sa
nouvelle vie c'est de s'habituer au
froid polaire de
Montréal même si j'ai mes
bottes de paires de
chaussettes je n'ai rien au
pieds aujourd'hui c'est vraiment froid
tu vois ça fait de la fumée quand je
parle la fumée sort de ma bouche sort de
mon
nez regarde tu vois elle
s'amuse ça te plaît
[Musique]
star avec toute cette
combinaison elle ne rentre même pas dans
la
balançoir mais elle s'amuse quand même
même sans pouvoir
s'assoir mon seul problème c'est que je
ne veux pas qu'elle tombe malade parce
que je n'ai pas d'assurance et pas
d'argent si elle tombe malade qu'est-ce
que je vais
faire avec 660 € d'IDE sociale dont la
moitié dépensé dans son
loyer faire vivre sa famille reste
compliqué pour Esther fa trouver un
travail
[Musique]
rapidement Amam la famille Ponti refuse
pour l'instant d'abandonner la vie
américaine qu' ont mis des années à
construire Chrisa la petite dernière est
l'une des pompom girl de son école
[Musique]
primaire
on est des pom pom girl on encourage
notre équipe en laquelle on croit on a
l'esprit d'équipe et on est toujours
prête merci pour ma
chaussure
christina est géniale elle est à la tête
de l'équipe elle est positive elle
encourage les filles elle les motive
aussi c'est un atout
majeurtina est l'une des meilleurs
élèves de cet établissement réputé
qu'elle fréquente depuis 5
ans l'année dernière elle a même intégré
la classe des
surdoués
quel est le volume du nouveau prisme de
combien les dimensions ont
changé donc la rép
c'est son talent c'est sa capacité à
s'exprimer verbalement elle est vraiment
très bonne pour
ça c'est une élève exemplaire elle est
très mature très indépendante très
motivé c'est tout ce qu'on cherche chez
une
[Musique]
élève
oou est Christina 18 cm C tu peux donner
la formule il faut multiplier la
longueur par la largeur par la hauteur
excellent cette élève parfaite est
promise un brillant avenir à seulement
10 ans Christina a déjà de grandes
ambitions qui forg l'admiration de ses
copines j'ira
soit à
ou Harvard et ensuite je veux être
médecin avocate et
gymnaste je ne sais pas comment c'est
possible mais j'admire ces
plans un avenir menacé par la
suppression du statut de protection
temporaire dont bénéficient ses parents
ils sont expulsables dans moins d'un
[Musique]
an Reny son papa est infirmier dans le
plus grand hôpital de
Miami il vit aux États-Unis depuis 18
ans il a garder l'habitude d'écouter la
radio
[Musique]
haïtienne ça à connecté
avec ma communauté
les question
c'est ici c'est c'est pas facile je sais
pas ce que je vais faire si je vais
pouvoir rester ici si je dois me
déplacer c'est c'est vraiment pas
facile je dois savoir ce qui se passe la
dernière fois la la semaine dernière
encore j'ai eu des nouvelles de
personnes qu'on a arrêté qu'on a déporté
c'est c'est c'est
vraiment ça me fait un peu peur
[Musique]
viens là viens là tout s'est bien
passé Chrisa et son frère Christopher
sont tous les deux nés ici ils sont
américains eu pourrai rester aux
États-Unis pas leurs parents Ry et sa
femme pensaient pourtant être de parfait
citoyens il travaillent P des impôts et
ont même pu s'offrir deux belles
voitures et cette grande maison le
comble de la réussite à
l'américaine bonjour Maman bonjour
Comment ça va bien et toi ça a été le
travail
bien ce rêve américain s'est forgé au
prix d'une déchirure familiale
le père de Christina a quitté Haïti du
jour au lendemain il y a 18 ans à cause
de persécution politique dont il ne veut
plus parler
aujourd'hui dans sa fuite il laisse
derrière lui son premier fils Olivier
qu'il confie alors à sa
grand-mère j'aimerais avoir une photo
plus récente il avait 9 ans 8 ans ans
maintenant il est il a 19 ans
je le connais mais on s'est jamais
vu on parle on se dit toujours qu'on
voudrait se voir plus que tout et il me
dit toujours quand je te verrai je vais
te
porter et te faire faire des tours comme
ça une famille déchirée qui pourrait
l'être à nouveau si les parents quittent
les États-Unis sans leurs deux enfants
américains alors ils ont décidé de se
battre grâce au talent doratrice de
Christina
son message impertinent et touchant au
président Trump a été vu plus de 25000
fois sur les réseaux
sociaux pas que BL des familles C sera
pour le business
l'économiesie président Trump je de on
des enfant américain et ce n'est pas
difficile à faire puisque vous êtes le
fils
d'immigr
cette vidéo lui a permis d'être invité
devant le Congrès américain et de
refaire passer le message au président à
la
télévision il a dit pendant sa campagne
qu'il voulait être le champion des
Haïtiens mais il ne s'y prend vraiment
pas bien je pensais qu'il ferait quelque
chose de bien plutôt que d'arrêter le
tps je pensais qu'il allait le
renouveler et qu'ensuite il allait
trouver une solution
permanente chezous
les États-Unis se sont construits avec
des immigrés il faut penser aux familles
car si on nous expulse cela créera des
séparations familial on ne peut pas
laisser nos enfants derrière nous il
faut qu'on reste
ensemble dans leur combat Reny et
Christina ne sont pas
seul ils peuvent compter sur
l'association des femmes haïtienne de
Miami dont Marline Bastien la présidente
est devenu le porte-parole de toute la
communauté men
c'est
race comme chaque année depuis le séisme
du 12 janvier 2010 elle organise une
marche de commémoration mais cette fois
la politique se mêle au
recueillement la veille Donald Trump a
tenu des propos insultants envers les
Haïtiens lors d'une réunion à la Maison
Blanche
apparemment il a dit et je cite pourquoi
tous ces gens des pays de merde viennent
iici oui vous avez bien entendu ce sont
les mots du président des
États-Unis pourquoi tous ces gens de
pays de merde viennent ici Donald Trump
faisait apparemment référence aux
nations africaines et Haïti avant de
suggérer que les États-Unis devaent
recevoir plus de gens venant de
Norvège des paroles qui choquent à la
veille du 8e anniversaire du
séisme nous sommes des êtres humains
comme tout le
monde Trump dit qu'on vient d'un pays de
merde ce n'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai
tout le monde dans ce pays est un
immigrant même la femme de Trump est une
immigrer pourquoi on aurait peur on ne
peut pas avoir peur
alléluia
alléluiati allez allez
allez alléluia allez allez allez je suis
un peu triste en pensant à Haïti mais
mais je suis pleine d'énergie hein pour
la bataille hein je suis très très très
très très
alléluia pleine d'énergie pour la
bataille
alléluia
[Applaudissements]
allélu
[Musique]
all si vous demandez à n'importe qui ils
vous diront
exactement où ils étaient il y a 8 ans à
ce moment
précis il est
16h53 un moment de
silence 53 le 12 janvier 2010 Haïti est
frappé par la plus grosse catastrophe de
son
histoire pendant une minute à peine la
secousse d'une magnitude de 7,3
l'équivalent de la force d'une bombe
atomique détruit toute la capitale de
port
auprce de nombreux bâtiments comme la
cathédrale ou le palais présidentiel
sont
ravagés 300000 personnes perdent la vie
autant de blessés 1 million et demi
d'Haïtiens deviennent sans
abri c'est après cette catastrophe que
le gouvernement américain offre le
statut de protection temporaire aux
[Musique]
haïtiensélu 8 ans plus tard le combat de
Marline Bastien est de rendre illég
[Musique]
z avec son avocat elle vient de déposer
une plainte contre Donald Trump en
personne
elle l'accuse de ne pas respecter la
Constitution
américaine
c'est une décision qui est basée sur le
racisme et le xyophobia mais pas sur les
faits alors c'est c'est pourquoi nous
nous nous organisons pour lutter contre
cette
décision notre plainte a deux fondements
premièrement la Constitution ne permet
pas la discrimination raciale pour
prendre ce genre de décision les
décisions éta basé sur la
race deèm et c'est très important le
gouvernement pas suivi la procédure et
les exigences requises pour le statut de
protection
permanente
exactement ils ont dit que les
conditions garantissant ce statut
n'existait plus tout le monde sait que
cela est
absurde et surtout on a découvert un
document confidentiel de
l'administration qui dit que ces
conditions existent
[Musique]
toujoursart dit l'administration Trump
aurait délibérément menti sur les
conditions de vie en Haïti pour expulser
58000 familles haïtienne et qui dans
cette plainte nous voulons que les les
les familles les 58000 familles avec le
statut
protégé obtiennent le droit de rester
ici à niveau permanent par serait
vraiment criminel de le de les envoyer
en Haïti ce serait vraiment criminel de
les envoyer en
Haïti parce Haïti maintenant et n'est
pas n'est pas
prêt alors quelle est vraiment la
situation en Haïti les conditions de vie
se sont-elles considérablement amélioré
depuis le tremblement de terre de 2010
comme l'affirme l'administration Trump
dans sa décision de supprimer le statut
de protection
temporaire nous nous rendons au nord de
la capitale porort auprce à
Canaan 300000 personnes pour la plupart
des familles ont été relogées ici à laav
vite après le séisme
ell vivent toujours dans ses habitations
de fortune dans une zone où le choléra
est
réapparu Laeticia Vaval est chargée de
mission à l'Office International
d'immigration affilié aux Nations
[Musique]
Unies il y a pas de service de santé il
y a pas de service d'éducation publique
gratuite on n pas l'électricité qui qui
a été amenée de façon formelle l'eau
courante bien sûr ne parlons pas de
l'assaainissement on n pas de système
d'assaainissement de système d'égoutût
vous pouvez voir là les tôes sont
attachés avec des pierres en fait ils
ont seulement posé des pierres et si un
ouragan venait nous frapper ces gens-là
sont tous vraiment à risque de perdre
leurs habitations de voir des
éboulements de
terrain depuis le séisme Haïti a aussi
été frappé par des ouragans destructeurs
Sandy en 2012 Matthew en 2016 Irma en
2017 les gouvernements successifs sembl
avoir baissé les bras face à une
reconstruction devenue
titanesque cette Française supervise
l'un des rares chantiers de Canaan la
construction de la toute première route
en
béton vous avez installé les pour global
ou il faut que l'ingénieur de Global
signe que c'est OK avant avant que vous
recouvriez il éta passé il a dit pas de
problème on estingénieur on a compris et
puis on l'
fait sont que des routes en TER battu
donc il a vraiment un problème de
poussière ENF surtout on a des des mois
qui peuvent passer sans qu'il pleuvent
et quand on passe avec un véhicule il y
a vraiment des énormément de poussière
ça do créer des problèmes respiratoires
chez les enfants donc là ce sera
vraiment la première route bétonnée
goudronnée qu'on va avoir cette aide des
ONG est pour l'URE la seule que les
habitants de canaon
reçoivent ils se sent abandonné par
l'État
haïtien
l'État ne nous aide pas à résoudre nos
problèmes on a rien à manger on ne peut
pas mettre nos enfants à
l'école l'État ne nous aide en rien
personne nous
aide n vraent pas
facile dans ce contexte comment des
dizaines de milliers de familles vivante
aux États-Unis pourraitelle être expulsé
ici
un scénario qui affaiblirait encore
davantage une nation touchée par un taux
de chômage record de 60
[Musique]
% à part au prince la question fait
débat jusque dans les cours de
philosophie de ce lycée du
centrevilleè une lecture de
Haï depuis 200 ans dans l'immobiler du
sousdéveloppement c'estàdire Haïti fait
fait face à une pass à une panne
existentiel parmi les 1000 élèves
scolarisés ici beaucoup vivent grâce à
l'argent que leur envoie une partie de
leur famille exilé aux États-Unis Haïti
tout entier sous perfusion de la
diaspora qui a envoyé en 2017 près de 2
milliards et demi de dollars au pays
1/ers de son PIB les qui Vinent des
États-Unis
[Musique]
constitue un apport un très grand apport
pour
l'économie tout le monde est concerné
c'est un CERC viciux c'est une ch c'est
déjà un paysz précire comme
ça il faut que le
[Musique]
présidentaisisseoupend la
chriquectualité
c'est dans ce lycée que nous rencontrons
Olivier le frère aîné de Christina la
petite américaine dont les parents sont
menacés
d'expulsion lui n'a pas eu la chance de
vivre aux États-Unis mais il partage la
même passion pour le basket que son
frère de
Miami alors on a de rencontrer parceon
veut vraiment jouer ensemble il dit
qu'il va Batt et moi également c'est
comme y a beaucoup de challeng mais
malheureusement pas encore l'occasion
pour se rencontrer pour jouer ensemble
jusqu'à présent mais on espère ça
viendra quand même tu l'as jamais vu
non Olivier n'a pas vu naître son petit
frère et sa petite sœur en Amérique il a
dû grandir sans ses
parents avec leur statut de résidence
temporaire ils n'ont jamais réussi à
obtenir de visa pour leur
fils j'ai toujours dit que ce n'est pas
de leur faute par que ce sont mes
parents donc ils veulent tout ce qu'il y
a de bien pour moi au contra c'est pour
cela qu'il travaill aussi dur pour
prièrement me mettre à l'école dans
cette école et donc et moiême ce que je
dois faire c'est travailler afin de
terminer mes études classiques et
ensuite je pense que
et je on pourra faire d'autres démche
pour qu'on soit enfin comme une famille
normale et qu'on vit ensemble tout ça
mais mais je demande toujours à ma
petite sœur de ne pas trop grandir parce
que j'aimerais le porter sur moi donc je
le demande de de ne pas trop grandir et
de ne pas trop grossir parce que
j'aimerais le taquiner un peu tout
ça malgré son traumatisme Olivier
affirme ne pas vouloir voir ses parents
revenir en Haïti et laisser derrière eux
leurs deux derniers enfants
américains
[Musique]
au Canada Esther a bien du mal à
s'habituer à un hiver
interminable après 6 mois à
Montréal cette maman célibataire cherche
toujours un travail
elle se rend ce matin à la Maison
d'Haïti une association qui aide les
réfugiés à s'insérer dans cette nouvelle
vie est-ce que vous m'entendez bien
est-ce que j'ai besoin de parler au
micro c'est correct comme
ça une entreprise de tisan québécoise
est ven recruter des ouvriers usine
d'emballage à 2h30 en gros c'est
vraiment de prendre les boîtes de thé
qui vont sortir de la production et
c'est un peu à la chaîne vous comprenez
donc c'est de prendre les boîtes de thé
regarder les mettre dans les caisses
faire l'empactage la
palletisation une cinquantaine
d'Haïtiens sont venus écouter la
présentation de cette entreprise qui
offre 40 heur de travail par
semaine pour convaincre les candidats
elle a même fait appel à un traducteur
créole on va vous expliquer
que si vous avez des difficultés pour le
transport on a la possibilité de mettre
en place un système de bus pour faire
l'aller-retour pendant 3 Moisant
3 esther est pleine d'espoir mais elle
va vite déchanter en apprenant les
horaires de 16h à 2h du
matin si vous venez nous rencontrer pour
avoir un poste de jour on ne peut pas
passer d'entrevue parce que c'est pour
des posts de soir seulement
les horaires de nuit ce n'est pas
possible c'est mon problème j'ai les
enfants j'aimerais pouvoir le faire mais
les horaires de nuit ça ne me convient
pas de 4h de l'après-midi à 2h du matin
ça ne va
pas donc non je ne peux pas
postuler une vingtaine d'autres
candidats se
présentent
okuis combien de temps vous êtesci à pe
prs
début le mois d'août le mois ok est-ce
que vous lisez le français oui d'accord
on faire un petit
test dites-moi en orange vous pouvez
lire en premier mais me lire qu'est-ce
qui est écrit des
ingrédients COD boîes vidéojeu ou l'ci
dans l'emplacement merveilleux c'est ça
jeouis mer donc vous vous êtes sans ENF
vous êtes disponible dès maintenant je
comprends
parfait une main d'œuvre disponible et
travailleuse qui comprend le français
pour ses recruteur l'afflux de migrants
haïtiens est une
obèe on a de la difficulté à trouver des
gens
présentement au
Québec dans nos industries moi je quand
même une industrie où c'est des
manœuvres des journaliers donc c'est
difficile ces temps-ci à à recruter
actuellement l'ouverture de nos
frontières au niveau de la migration
puis la facilité d'avoir les permis de
travail pour ces gens-là facilite
présentement nous notre travail au
niveau du
recrutement au final 12 personnes seront
embauchées ce
jour-là ester elle a repéré une
distribution de vêtements dans la pièce
d'à
côté qui a besoin d'un pantalon de
ski c'est garçon pour un garçon garçon
garçon
làtoilage ça c'est pour ma
fille pour mettre sous les
pantalons depuis un mois ou deux que je
viens là je me suis fait quelques amis
et ma fille s'amuse aussi de l'autre
côté donc il ne faut pas que je me dise
oh non pourquoi j'ai besoin de venir ici
non là je suis venue trouver du travail
et je repars avec des vêtements alors
c'est gagnant gagnant
le printemps s'installe enfin sur
Montréal avec le retour du BE temp le
chemin de rockam RO à la frontière
américaine voit défiler de plus en plus
de personnes qui fui les États-Unis
jusqu'à 500 par
jour
cette vague d'immigration irrégulière a
provoqué il y a quelques mois la
création de Storm alliance un groupe
nationaliste né de la rupture avec une
partie de l'extrême droite
[Musique]
ou salut salut c'est on VO je m'en va
rejoindre
le policier au bout du convi puis on
décolle Éric Trudel le chef de la
section du Québec organise ce jour-là
une manifestation à la frontière pour
demander la fermeture du chemin de
rockam Road
l'endroit est connu mondialement Mme
grâce à notre premier ministre Justin
Trudeau qui qui a fait un annonce son
Twitter en invitant tout le monde à
passer par les frontières même si
c'était illégal de le faire
c'est ça fait le tour du monde puis il
faut que ça arrête le plusôt possible le
convvoi d'une trentaine de voitures va
être accueilli par des contre
manifestants
[Musique]
antifascistes
qui que les gens sont pas la bienvenue
ici pas la capacité d'Ill tout le monde
les BL
plusut
c'est
J pour
Leser pour faire tampon entre les deux
camps la police québécoise déploie une
urgence des policiers
antimeut
l'affrontement est évité de
[Musique]
justesse notre pay c'est
notreéger la frontière on veut protéger
la
frontière 290 militants de Storm
alliance cri leur désaccord face à la
politique d'accueil des migrants de
Justin
trudauach
ité co très cher c'est N québis qui P
pour ça on a plein d'argent à mettre
HPUX on Ain d'argent à mettre
écoles au milieu des pancartes
antiimmigration quelques passoir censé
symboliser leurs frontières ces
manifestants n'acceptent pas que les
Haïtiens menacés aux États-Unis fu au
Canada en entrant de manière
illégale quand il f les éatsunis je
comprends le position mais par contre ce
que j'aime Mo c'est que il sont pas en
danger de mort
auats-unisump dem de par sont pas
régul juste
canadaourner dans le
Pay G sont pas en danger de mort pour la
généralité ils ont demandé un passeport
pour temps partiel aux États-Unis pu
passeport pmé Trump il fait son devoir
des mettre de c'est nous qui va ramaner
ça il y en est pas question Trump c'est
sa politique c'est son pays gère comme
il veut nous ce qu'on a à dire c'est que
c'est pas la faute de Trump sil y a des
immigrés quich également c'est ns
frontière c'est à nous des protéger on
est aujourd'hui pour réveiller nos fres
québécois qui reviennent la fin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tourner
tous unis pour notre P tous unis pour
notre P cette manifestation aura été la
première de l'année 2018 le groupe a
déjà annoncé de nouvelles actions au fur
et à mesure que le nombre de migrants
qui passe par le chemin de rockam Road
augmente devant ces pressions d'une
partie des Québécois la Gendarmerie
Royale tient à préciser que l'entrée au
Canada n'est pas si
facile les gens souvent ont l'impression
qu'en arrivant en passant la frontière
leur nouvelle vie commence ce qui est
important de mentionner par contre c'est
que ces gens-là viennent de commettre un
crime oui on les met en état
d'arrestation mais ça leur donne pas un
billet gratuit pour rentrer au Canada ça
c'est important de le dire parce qu'une
fois qu'il vont passer avec l'agence
service frontalier puis éventuellement
qu' vont faire leur demande ils doivent
être conscients qu'il y a plusieurs
demandes qui sont rejetées donc à ce
moment-là les gens sont retournés dans
leur pays c'est pas parce qu'ils mettent
le pied illégalement au Canada qui Devi
citoyen
Canadiens un tiers des demandes d'asile
seraiit rejeté dans ce cas les réfugiés
doivent quitter le
Canada au nord de Montréal Esther et ses
enfants profitent enfin des rayons de
soleil de cette fin de
printemps il fait beau tout va
[Musique]
bien on va au parc
il fait chaud ouvre ta veste un petit
peu jusquen bas oui
jusquenas près d'un an après avoir
quitté la Floride son dossier de demande
d'asile n'a toujours pas été
traitéendant vit aux États-Unis
réapprend le
français comment ça se passe cette
installation au Québec depuis plusieurs
mois en depuis je crois 10 mois presce
que la même chose je vi faire n chercher
Rava r trouvé pour les déker rien
trouvé c'est je pense c'était facile
mais ce n'est pas
facile ce n'est pas
facile
je sais que je ne suis pas la seule ils
ont plein de gens qui viennent ici mais
je ne pensais pas que ça allait être
aussi long je pensais qu'au bout de
quelques mois tout irait bien mais
non si son dossier est refusé Esther
sera renvoyé aux États-Unis où son
statut de protection temporaire n'est
désormais plus valable elle serait alors
expulsée vers
Haïti j'ai laissé mon pays il y a
longtemps quand je n'étais qu'une enfant
et quasiment toute ma famille a été tuée
là-bas les gens qui ont tué ma famille
sont toujours
là-bas alors si j'y retourne ils peuvent
s'en prendre à moi ils peuvent s'en
prendre à mes
enfants toutes les nuits je me réveille
en me disant non je ne peux pas aller
là-bas s'il me renvoie là-bas il signe
mon arrê de mort et vous savez seul dieu
le
sait
AmiAmi d'autres gardent l'espoir que le
Congrès américain revienne sur la
décision de Donald
Trump c'est un grand soir pour la petite
Christina tu vois c'est à
[Musique]
sortie
je ressemble à une petite poupée je suis
tellement
jolie merci maman
elle va recevoir un prix pour son
engagement en faveur des droits des
immigrésant
[Musique]
fam
[Applaudissements]
il va lui être remis par Marline Bastien
la présidente de l'Association des femme
haïtienne son
mentor
bonsoir je suis ici pour vous présenter
une belle jeune fille qui est une jeune
leader cette jeune leader est
intelligente
courageuse très mure pour son
âge
voici Christina
Pontieux nous avons une place en
Amérique vous savez pourquoi parce que
nous sommes des travailleurs parce que
nous méritons d'être là parce que nous
travaillons dur nous n'abandonnons pas
facilement mon père est infirmier ma
mère est infirmière mon frère est au
lycée et je suis en primaire et
maintenant nous nous battons dur pour
avoir le droit de
résidence le statut de protection
permanente vous êtes avec
moi qu'est-ce qu'on
veut qu'est-ce qu'on veut
en reconnaissance du super travail que
tu as fait à Washington et à travers
tous les États-Unis pour tous les
immigrés si je continue à me battre je
n'aurais plus à avoir peur chaque nuit
et chaque jour quand je suis à l'école
je n'auraai plus à me dire que quelque
chose va arriver donc ce prix veut dire
beaucoup pour pour moi parce qu'il me
donne la force de résoudre le problème
de mes parents et de beaucoup d'autres
familles la justice américaine étudie
toujours la plainte de la communauté
haïtienne contre le président Trump s'il
ne leur donne pas raison les parents de
Christina 58000 autres familles devront
quitter les États-Unis au plus tard le
22 juillet
[Musique]